es ist wieder zeit für einen test und
zwar nicht irgendeinen test sondern den
test vom schlechtesten döner in köln
kurz bevor es losgeht kommen wir zum
faktencheck die deutschen essen ungefähr
40 megatonnen döner im monat das sind
umgerechnet zwei fußballfelder kopflos
wenn ich sage der schlechteste dünner
dann stellt ihr euch bestimmt die frage
worauf beruf ich mich und das war
tatsächlich gar nicht mal so leicht es
gibt nämlich keinen super schlechten
döner dann haben die dänen zwar ein
stern von fünf aber auch nur eine
bewertung und dann bin ich auf einen
block gestoßen
der nennt sich der döner tester das ist
eine anonyme person die auch aus köln
kommt und die hat es sich eben zur
aufgabe gemacht jegliche bilder laden in
köln zu testen und praktischerweise kann
man auf der seite auch filtern so was
ihr euch jetzt zeigen werde
klingt ganz schön hart und mach dich
unbedingt lust das ganze auszutesten
aber ich finde eigentlich einfach nur
fair weil das ist ein erlebnis und eine
bewertung und wir müssen natürlich als
größter bester schönster reichster
puttkammer in deutschland auch eine
wertung nicht alle sauer werden ich bin
nicht der größte bekomme ich weiß also
dass der döner tester bei dem laden
handelt es sich um city döner und er hat
eine bewertung von 4,35 das sind
schulnoten wohlgemerkt also fast
ungenügend und das ist bei döner schon
wirklich schwer weil ich meine drehspieß
immer gleich man kauft das fleisch beim
großhandel klar qualitätsunterschiede
aber schon ähnlich alles in allem muss
da schon einiges schief gehen wir gucken
mal was wirklich schief gegangen ist
öffnungszeiten 6 bis 22 uhr fast jeden
tag stabil preis 4 euro vollkommen okay
ich glaube da streiten sich auch die
geister
alle berliner werden sagen er ist
übertrieben teuer alle schweizer werden
sagen dafür kriege ich bei uns in der
schweiz zwei erbsen für kölner
verhältnisse vollkommen in ordnung
der döner texter kategorisiert in
fleisch brot saucen salat service
sauberkeit und gesamtnote und ihr seht
hier fleisch 4,5 vorgeschnitten und
lache rick brot 5,5 also fast 6 laden
großartiges gebilde leicht erwärmt
bricht direkt auseinander
sauce 3,0
tatsächlich lecker scharfe soße war so
wenig dass sie zusammen gekratzt werden
musste salat zu viel flüssigkeit die
durch den döner sich ihr merkt es der
dürrner tester hat kein gutes haar an
dem laden gelassen aber wir schwingen
uns jetzt auf die vespa und testen das
ganze selbst gute 20 minuten später sind
jetzt in köln porz angekommen und das
ist schon eine ganz andere geschichte
als bei dem schlechtesten restaurant
dass wir getestet haben
hier ist glaube ich wenig laufkundschaft
deshalb ist es umso interessanter dass
dieser döner so schlecht sein soll wir
bestellen jetzt genauso wie der döner zu
essen bestellt hat und dann gucken wir
mal ob's stimmt warum machst du ich bin
vor ihr auch sehr gespannt decca und ich
finde es so wenn ihm dass er hier ist
vielleicht hat ja der döner tester auch
irgendwie ein problem mit dem inhaber
oder so wir haben beide so moderaten
hunger also perfekte voraussetzungen zum
testen ich freue mich aber auch weil
irgendwie hoffe ich dass es gut wird die
jungs da drüben laufen habe ich gerade
angequatscht wir haben gesagt der döner
geht eigentlich voll klar also die
konnten es zumindest nicht
nachvollziehen
deshalb bin ich mal gespannt ob wir
einen guten tag haben also ob der döner
test an schlechten tag hatte wir
bestellen natürlich genau die gleiche
bestellung also komplett city scharfe
soße salat schon mal was los ist erst
mal ein gutes zeichen laden eigentlich
gute lage sind direkt an einer großen
bahn haltestelle hamburger cheeseburger
ganz normaler döner laden oder
ja ja aber es auch eher die ausnahme das
dinner denn so krank stylish sind so
hallo wir hätten gern zwei große döner
bitte menschen gerne fordere
alles scheint sauber zu sein jetzt nicht
super stylisch aber das land ist dass
vier euro für deine bühne
getränkeauswahl stabil frische backwaren
die steinbacher es kommt auf den döner
an ja das stimmt ihre juni an ist im
laden sondern wendet euch lieber auch
was lernen sagt weißen espresso fire
fire damit auf das heim findet das war
ein bisschen das habe zwar nichts
schicken was pizza ofen gebacken wurde
das fleisch nehmen wir so auf die hand
oder packen lassen es uns einen packen
mehr direkt auf die hand
jetzt hilft ja auch nicht genug von
bahnsteigs wenn du von der arbeit nach
hause kommt mit nach hause
15 leute in dem kleinen laden stabil
also rein optisch weit hinter dem schon
hundertmal feld nächsten negative oder
positive antwort standen zwei stücke
anders oder gerne komplett genau 20 und
scharfe soße und salat
ja genau die hand gerne direkt danke
sehr schönen tag noch
er sich übertrieben stabil aus also bin
jetzt wirklich sehr sehr gespannt wie
das ganze schmecken wird könnte mir
vorstellen dass wir positiv überrascht
werden wir gehen jetzt gar nicht groß
weit wir sind direkt 50 meter vom laden
es mit dem döner fresh mit wir auch
nicht irgendwie durch unser verschulden
ein weiches brot haben oder so wie jetzt
bin ich gespannt wir gucken uns das
ganze gleich erstmal im detail an also
es riecht erstmal überhaupt nichts
komisch ist es nicht toll wunderschön
gemacht also der fällt ein bisschen was
raus aber wir haben knuspriges brot
hertner scharfe soße waren ein bisschen
spaß haben das mag sein aber ansonsten
ein gutes produkt ist immer gleich ja
wir haben genau das gleiche bestellt
haben zwei unterschiedliche leute
gemacht haben wie andere reihenfolge
gurke tomate rotkohl salat
hähnchenfleisch scharfe soße 24 euro
dies komplett okay aber ich meine ja
schon preispunkt hat jeder andere
vorstellungen einzelnen produkte jetzt
mal wirklich testen leisten kay
salatgurke 100% frischfleisch meinte er
glaube ich dass sex noch billig gewesen
normales dönerfleisch noch mal ganz kurz
ins gedächtnis rufen der angeblich
jahren echte genannt sondern in köln
bisher frage ich mich warum das hier der
angeblich schlechteste boehner in köln
sein soll ich klar das ist mir eins für
meinung muss man dazu auch sagen warum
so besser dass ich die vielleicht durch
meinen eindruck gerade rücken kann ich
will aber gar nicht mehr lange rum reden
weil an sich habe ich nicht mal so
zurückhaltung vor dem döner sondern habe
aber zu probieren
also mir jetzt passt durch das einzige
was ein bisschen aufgefallen ist gegen
ende ein bisschen viel bist was geht
mich fühle mich nicht schlecht wenn er
froh den döner zu essen wenn das der
schlechteste döner in köln sein soll
dann hat köln auf jeden fall keinen
döner problem da sind wir also wieder
leute war auf jeden fall interessant
also ich muss sagen es war anders als
ich erwartet hätte für den schlechtesten
döner in köln den angeblich statisten
döner in köln aber wir gehen noch einen
schritt zurück und gucken uns mal die
bewertung von boehner testern also ihr
seht hier fleisch hat von ihm eine 4,5
bekommt war bei uns nicht so ich gebe
dem fleisch eine 3,0 ist war zwar frisch
vom spieß geschnitten aber es war
einfach durchschnitt hält befriedigen
übrigen ja also quasi mit drei brot 5,5
da muss ich eigentlich komplett
widersprechen es war nicht dieses geile
selbstgebackene runde döner brot da wir
wisst was ich meine deshalb bisschen
absurd 2,5 wir bleiben kritisch weil es
gibt auch krasse krasselt mit soße 3,0
bei uns hat es an nichts gemein mit soße
war genug da fand sie sogar echt lecker
weil sie so ein bisschen knoblauch weg
warst ich gebe 2,0 für ihn ist das ja
schon der beste punkt für mich noch
besser salat 4,5 zu viel flüssigkeit die
durch den döner dürfte der salaten das
gemüse waren astrein also quasi
automatischer frisch selbst auch muss
ich nur 20 geben also der war wirklich
top service 4,0 aufforderung zur fleisch
wirklich einen befehl die haben es ja
mit nachdruck zum langen geraten das ist
ein bisschen negativ aufgefallen gehe
ich auf 3,8 und sauberkeit 4,5 überall
krümmel bei uns gar nicht erst nicht
klinisch sauber aber das ist nur 20
zum glück gibt es kein faktor aus den
vom laden weil ich krank der laden war
nicht toll so aber für einen döner wurde
auch vollkommen in ordnung ich jetzt
hier nochmal eine gesamtnote 1 in jedem
fall deutlich besser als die 4,35 vom
döner tester und ich bin froh dass es so
war also heckflossen doch auch gegessen
was sagst du zu dem dinner
das war diese richtig dieser döner den
früheren seiner großen pause holt man
war einfach völlig zufrieden also nichts
daran auszusetzen jan er so auf dem
schulweg nach hause
gegessen und sondern war einfach happy
so ja ich will auch gar nicht im döner
tester vorwerfen dass er irgendwie mit
dem vorsatz die dumm dastehen zu lassen
hingegangen ist der hat wahrscheinlich
recht einen schlechten tag erwischt wir
hatten jetzt ein guten in jedem fall
danke dass ihr das video angeschaut habt
positive überraschung für uns zum glück
leckeres mittagessen aber in zukunft
werden wahrscheinlich auch weniger gute
überraschung dabei sein deshalb bleibt
auf jeden fall am start beim kanal
abonniert gern lassen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
macht gut und scharf